and good morning everybody and welcome
to trafford kobe 19 public engagement
board
i'm today chairing on behalf of the
council leader
andrew weston um as he is on another
meeting
and i'd like to um
note that we have an apology for absence
obviously from andrew and also from
helen grant
and if we can move to the agenda i'd
like to look at
item two are there any declarations of
interest
no indication of declarations of
interest so if those can be recorded
thank you
um item three the minutes of the last
meeting held on the 21st of september
and i wasn't at the meeting so if people
could have a
look and if they can be approved please
i could approve that enough yeah so
they're approved thank you very much
um moving on then um to item four
so can we have an update on the current
kovid 19th situation in trafford
that's over to you eleanor and obviously
the weekend
uh didn't look great so uh we welcome
your report thank you
well yes this this report was written on
friday
and um people will have heard over the
weekend that we had a lot
more cases i think um so over the
weekend
and looking at the data that we've got
come in just literally half an hour ago
from the um up to the second of
september so from the data from the
now the 27th
through to the second sorry 26th through
to the second
we have had 506 cases in this last week
um and that gives us a rate of 213.
so that's it that rate could go up
further because this is just the data
that with the
um the data for um saturday and sunday
can increase
further so i think we're in a very
different position than we were even a
couple of weeks ago
um we've seen this dramatic increase
we're continuing to see
cases across the whole of the borough
and we've seen that to be fair we've
seen that throughout and i think that's
been one of
my main concerns about the situation in
trafford has been the um the spread
of the cases um but
like every like other places in the
country we are seeing increasing cases
in our particularly our 18 to 21 year
old 17 to 21 year olds
the the overall position even with these
additional
cases doesn't change from the um
statement that i made which is that they
mainly are
in the um that working age population
big chunk in that um if you like the
sort of students in college
age population not so many in our school
age population
unfortunately at the moment still not so
many in our
population of people aged over 65
and that's really what we're wanting to
make sure we keep we do keep infection
away from our older age groups
but with the level of community
transmission that we're seeing
it is going to be extremely difficult to
keep that infection away from people
without people really making some quite
dramatic changes to their behavior
i think this is we're at a situation now
where
the spread is too widespread there are
too many cases in our community
but this just to be managed through test
and trace and identifying individual
cases
we really do need everyone to start
changing their behavior
quite significantly and and really also
just thinking about the fact that
um while it is a mild disease for many
people it isn't
for there are people throughout the
community who will be i'm seriously ill
from it
at any age and also the the increasing
number of people we're seeing suffering
long covered
and that really quite debilitating
illness following it
so it i suppose my main message is this
is something we need to take extremely
carefully to
treat extremely um
we need to really act now to it to
address this and and to start bringing
our numbers down
um and people need to be very very much
more cautious i think than
perhaps they are at the moment and think
about how we protect ourselves
better so i think that's all i want to
say about this at the moment
um yes
very very high rates and going up and
going up quite sharply
so i don't know if anyone has any
questions
anybody has any questions if you can
indicate um with
the raised hand and then i'll in i'll
bring people in thanks ellen
and i know it must be really difficult
and quite demoralizing when all the hard
work that you've done over the last
seven months and you know the rates are
rising again and
let's hope that we can sort of like
bottom that out before
we have winter flu on top so thank you
for all you do
and and you and your team thank you does
anybody
wish to ask any questions
okay joe i was just going to ask
um eleanor whether some of the increases
is it down to
testing results coming in late or
anything like that
so the big increase that we've just seen
um
this week is because we've suddenly got
a whole load of tests coming in late so
our rates were higher than we knew but
what we've also
seen is um a sharp increase anyway
so our single biggest number of cases
on a single day was on thursday last
week where we had 122 positive cases
all in one day so those that wasn't
affected by the late results coming in
so we it's it's not so what i would say
is we've been seeing
what we've what we're seeing now with
the case of the extra cases that come
have come in and there were a
significant number of extra cases that
came in
but all that's done is show us that that
graph of
rising cases is a sharper graph of
rising cases
it isn't that we got those results and
actually we don't have a problem because
our rates are
have come down again our rates are
starting to really go
up speedly um
so yes the other thing is that we do
know
i think there will be some need to have
a a look
potentially um with some of the student
cases whether they are registered at
whether they're still using their gp
address and as um
whether their nhs number brings up their
home registered address rather than
their university address
and whether some of these are cases who
are elsewhere
but and so we will start we'll we'll be
doing a a real look at that big
cohort of cases that we're coming
through um and also looking at other
areas figures
um manchester obviously is in a very
difficult position
and has even more cases in that age
group than we do
well thanks joe and george did you
indicate i'm sorry that
i said that if people could raise their
hand you know because i thought we were
at that
system where you could click your hand
and it came up in the participation bar
it doesn't so if you want to speak if
you just
let me know in chat and then we'll bring
you in george it's over to you
yeah just um wondering about
well two things really what are the
implications of continued
rise and what's the time scale for any
changes
that might be made to the current
position
sorry um the implication of the
continued rise
is that we will start seeing in about
nine weeks time we will start seeing
deaths that are related to the current
rates rather than the
what we're seeing at the moment is
probably um
a nine week lag between the infection
rates going up and and the death rates
increasing
and hospitalization rates obviously as
well have quite a lag
at the moment we are still seeing it
mainly in our younger and healthier
population
and to that extent and our treatment has
got better
for covid so to that extent at the
moment
we're not seeing we from
today's data we're not expecting to see
well we will it's more we will start
seeing these cases unless we can really
work out how
to separate these of different
populations which we can't
we cannot separate these populations
effectively so the options i think are
um that we will have to start looking at
what other
um what other uh
lockdown type restrictions arrangements
that get put in place in trafford and
across the northwest but
i mean potentially across the whole
country when you start looking at the
rates that in
rising as they are um the longer we wait
the more we'll have to do and the longer
we'll have to do it for
i mean i think the the good news is that
we're not seeing it in the school age
population and i i really do want to
commend
the head teachers um for all the work
that they've been doing to keep the
school
safe because that is absolutely
phenomenal work and at the moment in
trafford we're not seeing
out we're seeing cases linked to schools
but we're not seeing very many
outbreaks within the schools and so that
element
is working well that that identification
very quickly
and the closing down of the bubbles but
obviously that can be very disruptive
for
the families for schools for teaching
and so on i'm very keen as you know that
we do keep the schools open
i think that's absolutely paramount that
we have to keep the schools open
we have to have a way of educating our
students as well
but at the moment
i would say it's very hard to see how we
get these numbers down
unless businesses and all of us start
working
behaving really differently we've
we can't we can't get these numbers down
and you know it will be about how else
would you manage the consequences
because there will be consequences from
rates this high
thanks eleanor
does anybody else want to come in
counselor welton um
hi um thanks eleanor that's quite a i
mean it's quite a bleak
picture you picture you paint do we have
any indication of transmission from the
um
you know the teenage early 20s
population to their families i know that
you said previously that we have
haven't had many instances where you
know whole families have got infected
and and that kind of thing you know is
that
surely if we we've now had relatively
high rates among
that age group since july certainly
higher than the rest of them
so
we've lost your counselor welton you
seem to have frozen
um yes chairs through you i believe it
might be um
an internet um issue connection
if you listen to them i'm here now but
uh
so if you just want to finish the end of
your question so well enough and come in
thanks
yes it is you know we've we've had high
rates
among the young people for uh you know
for for a long time but
but previously we've said that we're not
getting kind of whole families or whole
households
infected um i'm just
you know i'm interested to know how you
know
we're seeing large rates but we're not
you know are we going to see
large rates of infection of older people
you know you
thought we'd be seeing whole households
um you know becoming infected if the
if if the teenagers who are living there
are getting it as well
that's something that's a really good
question and that's something we are
starting to look at
i would say that our our rates are above
in each
every age group now are above 50 per
hundred thousand apart from in our
youngest children
um we're mainly testing symptoms the
data that we have shows that we're
mainly testing symptomatic people
uh so over 90 percent are symptomatic at
the time that they
that they state they have symptoms at
the time that they're being tested
our positivity rates on the last um set
of data
that i have before which is up till the
um 29th of september our positivity
rates were 11
so while we're testing more people we're
seeing an awful lot more people who are
testing positive
um so i think these are not most of
these people are genuinely are ill
and are likely therefore to be spreading
the disease
i think that these our positivity rate
has gone up
um we are starting we are have seen
throughout some whole households being
infected and clearly from household
mixing
mixing with other households what we are
seeing now
and we'll be doing more data we're going
to be doing a deep dive
now with this latest data set to see
what's happening in the households
and um i've asked out we've got a new
data analyst now we have had been short
of
analytical capacity but i've asked him
to go through with
to look at all of the 17 to 21 year olds
from
from july onwards because we've had
quite a big cohort up and down with that
group
um to look at what else is going on in
the households
and to see whether we're picking up
whole household transmission
or how many how much spread there is
again
you would expect um transmission to be
limited
in households if people are able to um
socially distance within the household
so in effect the less overcrowded the
house the easier it is to do that social
distancing
um and also where people have for
example more than one bathroom
then the ill person can use that
bathroom and so on so
i i would expect to see in some parts of
trafford it much easier to manage
and reduce infection risk than in other
areas so we'll be looking at all of this
and trying to
to reinforce but again it's reinforcing
those messages about if somebody is in
ill in your household you know do treat
them as if they have flu or as if they
have
vomiting and diarrhea do try and make
sure that you keep
keep you know scrupulous hygiene within
the house to try and stop that spread
but we will be doing those analyses and
i'll report back
thank you
i think khan has got us yeah sorry i i
think i've
muted myself again then sorry um
sorry thank you my question relates to
the delay in uh
there's a time lag between taking a test
and getting a result um
because the results we're getting today
are obviously a few days old
because i know some people have have
actually struggled to get their tests
out because they have to wait a few days
maybe six seven eight days before they
got the result of the test
so really the situation today could be
much worse than we are seeing
at this stage that's certainly what we
discovered over the weekend because of
those lab test delays
um so there have been two issues one has
been
um so many lots of tests being done
leading to lack of capacity in the labs
to analyze the tests
and the backlog of test results coming
out and the second issue which is the
issue that
came to light over the weekend was some
people were actually getting the people
were getting the results
but they weren't being entered onto the
system so the test and trace people
weren't able to follow up
and obviously that means that by the
time they're able to get hold of people
and talk to them about their contacts
the opportunity to break that
transmission is lost
um i think at the moment what we'll be
focusing and this is something that i
really would like the support of the
board on
and perhaps this um we can discuss this
more as as we would move through the
agenda
i think we really need to be looking at
how we do that backward tracing contact
tracing so not only
stopping the root of infection going
forward but also
really identifying where did people pick
the infection up from
and what does that tell us about the
sorts of settings that we need to be
taking particular precautions in
to reduce those infection risks so what
can we learn about how people got the
disease
so that we can put additional
precautions in to stop other people
getting the disease in similar settings
and i think that is the piece of work we
really need to be focusing
on now as well as the forward contact
tracing
actually that settings based
preventative work
which and again members of this group
i'm sure will be very helpful with
with thinking about how we can how we
can really address some of that
[Music]
thank you eleanor and i can see no more
indication so
oh lord you want to come in sorry
sorry i mute myself um so eleanor i was
just going to ask another question i
know we talk about data loads
anyway in the team don't we but um in
terms of the shape of that that graph
and the cohort being the younger
population do you think that some of the
shift will be in relation to the first
wave
affecting the older population and i
suppose is that
because it was an upside down pyramid
triangle at first wasn't it and now it's
a kind of
a right way up triangle so i suspect
would at some point we expect as that
kind of herd immunity spreads to see the
shape
become you know diagonal
um potentially but i think
probably we had as many young people
infected in the first wave but we
weren't testing them
because we were only testing people who
were seriously ill in the first day what
stage so in the first stage the average
age of people we were testing was about
80
in april um because it was mainly people
who were
ill enough to end up in hospital so in
the second now
because we've got community-based
testing we're testing people who are
relatively well um then that's why i
think we're seeing so many younger
people
coming forward so i suspect you could
add all of if
i think probably the fairer comparison
to make will be between our pillar one
tests now and our and the previous curve
and those tests are still much lower so
we are testing people and we will
because we're testing people when
they're
probably picking it up earlier in the
infection their infection because we're
not waiting for them to need to go to
hospital
we are picking up um people who are
um less ill at the point of testing
definitely
so we we're picking up it's just a very
very different cohort now but with
we're seeing we're picking people up
earlier and younger
thank you elena and if we can move on
now to item
five communication and engagement system
connectivity i think
the part a might be you again eleanor is
it or is it
martin i think it's me actually is it
oh is it you laura sorry i think so yeah
um i don't it might be worth
um throwing up fabiola the paper if um
if you may
and i won't i won't spend too long on
this
governor not the most exciting topic in
the world
um but really what i wanted to to do was
to just sort of demonstrate
um kind of in reflection of what ellen
has just said about
rising rates and how we're trying to
respond to this
internally um so so
what this paper sort of sets out to do
is essentially map out the kind of the
infrastructure that we think that we've
got in place
um to support this board um so you can
see in the middle of the diagram there
we've got the public engagement board
to support the board in in the work
because obviously this
this response is really about trying to
mobilize
every team within the council that has
an interest in uh community engagement
work with all of our partners and make
sure that we've kind of got
you know a finger in every pie so to
speak and we've got our
key population cohorts covered um
through our governance and through that
system connectivity
so essentially
underneath the public engagement board
we've got a health and social care
engagement steering group
and i know that tom's going to provide
an update on the kind of strategic
direction of that
in a minute and then what we've done
underneath that board is
set up sort of three new groups really
um and the rest of this agenda and
hopefully this sort of frames the agenda
is to
to provide a bit of feedback as to what
what those groups are doing
and how they are kind of responding um
data
engagement coordination group and that's
very much um
uh kind of a partnership group it's got
a lot of our
um key teams within the council so we've
got environmental health we've got
strategic partnerships we've got
comms licensing we've got thrive and
that's very much talking about the data
and ellen has just talked to you on a
weekly basis
and setting out an action plan and then
we've got our covid19 enforcement group
which has recently been
re-mobilized and i think neil's going to
provide an update from
from that in a minute in terms of the
work that's going on there
and that's very much more around
kind of driving the enforcement activity
and the the
kind of the national legislation and
making sure that
we've got the kind of regulatory
response in place
and then we've also got this virtual
comms network
which is essentially our kind of working
with
all various different sectors and as we
kind of develop key messages we
can contact them and with the hope that
they can kind of disseminate
key information to the wider communities
and make sure that we've got that kind
of reach
um so so as i said more of an assurance
piece really just to kind of demonstrate
and there's going to be a lot more
boards i think that would
that would play a role so you can see
they've got start well live well aidwell
which comes off the health and wellbeing
board there's going to be a whole load
of other
groups but what we're going to try to do
is make sure
and if we go to appendix a
this is kind of work in development
really but what we've tried to do here
is kind of map out what we think the key
population cohort groups are
and then along the top and then on the
left-hand side
the the kind of the key system
governance that we've got in place that
sort of
um represents those groups
and just to make sure that we can reach
everybody
through the governance that we've got in
place internally um
so just an ask really that you're
comfortable with this approach and will
carry on doing the mapping
and if you think we've missed any key
groups
that that we aren't managing to reach or
that we've not represented there um
just to let us know
thank you laura does anybody have any
questions or is there any comments that
people would like to make around the
paper and
the proposal that laura's just raised
you're on new counselors later
can you hear me now i don't have to work
this computer i'm so
sorry i'm just a good job i'm just
andrew's understudy isn't it
sorry about that any questions anybody
please just indicate
and then we can have a discussion about
the comments that laura's made thank you
councillor welton did you indicate
i've had no other indication so thank
you laura everybody must think that's
spot on
oh hang on i think there's something in
the chat
looks good so everybody seems very
satisfied with that thank you very much
laura
and if we move on then to the second
paper um
is that you diane
myself sorry i'm giving everybody bits
of work
sorry just keeping you all on your toes
thank you um i apologize in advance
because i think my internet connection
is very poor this morning so i've
previously turned my video off and i'm
not too sure whether
um if it does get to a point where you
can't hear me hopefully tracy
can very ably step in to support the
rest of the item
and but i'll lead us off i don't want to
spend too much time on this because i
think the
the benefit will be in the conversations
that follow in the remaining agenda
items
but we did discuss this very briefly a
couple of previous uh public engagement
board meetings around
the need for bond strategy around health
and social care communications and
engagement
um some people would will be familiar
with that we
launched and signed off our trafford
together locality plan which was the
five-year strategy
for health and social care in the
borough at the back end of last year
and as we moved into implementation um
covered came upon us and what that did
is it enabled us to give us a
a re-look at how we do comes in
engagement
as part of that that a dealt with covid
and the the unbelievably important
messaging and engagement
um that we need to do as part of the
pandemic that we're currently in the
middle of
but also to have one view to the
five-year future as well
so actually how do we move from just
very simple communications to that more
co-production approach and doing things
together
um so ultimately the strategy that
people will have
and had a look at previously um goes
into detail around
how we're going to have consistent
branding how we're going to utilize all
our communications channels
throughout all our respective partners
how we're going to do this completely in
partnership
um and this the communications and
engagement steering group that laura
referred to and showed in her system
diagram
is a great example of how 16 plus
organizations have come together to
co-produce this document
um inevitably there will still be some
refinement needed and the devil will
be in a detail so that action plan
around how we deal with covid now
through the groups that laura's
articulated
plus i think this lays the platform and
this way of working around kobe lays the
platform for the longer term
and as i said before how we move towards
that more
co-production approach to everything
that we do um
there's some really key core components
of the strategy
around promoting equality around
understanding risk in our system and
none so more important at the moment
than covered it is about how we measure
success and whether or not that comes in
engagement work that we are doing
whether or not it's actually having an
impact
so we do need to actually assure
ourselves and test ourselves
um in terms of are we making a
difference
become part of the local care alliance
dashboard as we move
forward um and there's a section there
on measuring success which people can
digest in the long term
and very broadly i just want to
acknowledge the great effort of 16 plus
partners who have contributed to the
development of the strategy
um it's been a lot of hard work a lot of
volunteer led time from people on this
call and people who are part of the
steering group
and so i just wanted to place my my
thanks on record the most important part
now
is actually how we mobilize that
strategy into very practical tangible
actions
through the engagement group and through
the virtual comms network
and through the steering group in terms
of that strategic steering holding the
different programs of work together
and so we need to do the hearing now
absolutely but we need to do that
proactive work around
um i think yes sorry for you yes tom we
cannot hear you
now
i'm happy to take over the final bit
and so i work with tom on then
developing the constant engagement
strategy
and so in terms of that yeah we just
really need to finalize and i think
the the work that laura has has just
previously said and trying to
really align everyone together a little
bit more really does focus and gives us
a real focus now
on what we need to do and actually
um some of the engagement work will be
following straight after
this meeting as well now so we have a
group that's set up to meet straight
afterwards as well
so we really do try and deliver actions
as soon as public engagement board has
finished
[Music]
so um tom's back
i am sorry i really do apologize for my
my poor internet connection
um i'm not too sure where i got cut off
then and my screen just completely froze
and
threw me out um so the idea is that we
would really welcome people's comments
and thoughts on this i know a lot of
you've been involved in producing the
document as it currently stands
the idea is that by the end of this week
we submit um the final version of this
strategy and take it to the health and
well-being board meeting
for its full formal support which is
taking place on the 16th of
october and so really welcome any any
comments and suggestions of how we could
potentially improve this document thank
you
thanks tom and tracy um does anybody
have any questions or comments that
they'd like to make at this point thanks
i think diane wants to come in yes i am
thank you chair it was just really to
ask if if there were
quick messages we need to get to the
group part of the strategy is around
having that sort of
um text messaging or um
more modern whatsapp things that we can
speak to people very quickly that may be
an issue as we go into this week
with the rates going up so quickly we
may need to advise the group quickly of
actions we're taking so if we can make
sure we've got contact details for
everyone with the
commslee so that we can we can enact
that if we need it
thank you
you diane um anybody else got any
questions or comments
no thank you if we can then move on to
item six it's a ten point plan update
is that you eleanor
i think we've got neil actually yeah
it's neil is updating on this
we're doing lots of changes of voices so
neil is updating on the
um engagement work today thank you neil
hello i have the uh the enforcement
paper i've not at this stage been sent
the
the the engagement one so if it's all
right everybody let's just move on to
the enforcement one
um so um
as far as background there is an
enforcement subgroup
that's been running since uh the
beginning of the pandemic in in
or since march and that's chaired by
um by adrian fischer the director of
growth and
regulatory services that comprises
environmental health
community safety licensing greater
manchester police
the housing providers our legal team
our comms team and representatives from
the public health team
and and the idea of that group really is
to understand the data
um and to coordinate responses that may
require
um some enforcement of the regulations
and it does link into the uh the
engagement
um work stream um as far as
updates from that um that group the idea
really is to
to make sure that not only that that
actions are coordinated but
we're not duplicating our efforts and
that we're not being
inefficient um as far as updates town
centers
um offices from our licensing team from
gmp
um from environmental health and then
also some of our elected members
have been out to town centres and have
had the opportunity to check that
current legislation is being added to
and the businesses in particular
licensed premises and residents
understand
what's actually required of them uh
where outbreaks have
occurred in particular premises either
advice or enforcement
um activity might be required and
officers when they go out engage with
those business owners and managers
supervisors around that
uh and that further um further work is
going to take place
um within town centers to include
evening work to monitor compliance with
with regulations we've also done some
work with the transport network
um the community safety team along with
gfgm
and gmp have undertaken now a couple of
operations around face cover and
compliance
uh on public transport and the aim was
really to make sure
not just that people were aware when
they needed to wear when we saw for
example
one of those operations as people
entered ultra interchange
people really weren't aware that they
had to wear one in the interchange they
thought it was just
on the train um but also where people
had forgotten the face covering or
didn't have one
um one was able to be provided at no
charge to them
um that was a really positive operation
it's really interesting to see
um most people were were wearing those
masks most people were in compliance
um and and those that weren't it was
mostly forgetfulness there were one or
two that were quite
unpleasant about having to wear one but
when the
uniform police officers approached the
tune changed significantly
um with residential premises we've had a
number of reports of gatherings
within residential premises and those
are managed between gmp
and the council's community safety team
um that does involve a proportionate
approach
uh but a stepped approach uh for minor
breaches so where there is
you know deliberate disregard for the
regulations or
refusal to comply uh on attendance
um the fixed penalties can and have been
issued as far as that's concerned
um there's been some um some reports
received
also regarding uh quarantine whether
people who are uh required to quarantine
have been doing so
uh and that requires a really joined up
approach uh the the
my understanding is that is taking place
between both the local authority great
manchester police
and also uh border force um
and then um the council and gmp are
working very closely together
um to ensure that organizers of large
events
are aware of the regulations and are
adhering to those regulations to make
sure that if we are having events
that they can be delivered safely for
next steps
the group will continue to meet on a
weekly basis
this afternoon and we'll share
intelligence and information to plan
actions and operations as necessary um
some of the gm boroughs are meeting more
regularly than this
and the frequency of those meetings will
be reviewed
regularly and the work of the group
is currently met by existing resources
but uh
will need to be kept under review in
case circumstances change
that's that if anybody has any questions
i'll i'll endeavor to
to answer them thank you neil if anybody
that's got any questions do you want to
indicate
thank you very much for that it was
really informative and if we
it was another part today um
is it the the escalation of the health
and social care communication engagement
oh no sorry i'm going backwards oh no
i'm not
and you want me to i can see that sorry
sorry item c i tried to print it all off
because i really like
paper and printering ran out this
morning
so i'm having to try and read this on my
ipad and i
i hate having to read off of
an electronic device so if you can move
on that's brilliant thank you
um so i think we jumped a didn't we so i
just just add to what neil said so we've
got these two groups we've got the
enforcement group and then we've got the
um the kind of overall
um coordination group so just a couple
of other things that the team are doing
internally so our environmental health
team have been working with businesses
um in the borough that aren't displaying
a qr code
and making sure that we kind of contact
them to make them aware of the rules in
the restaurants
we've also got teams picking up the
market
so i think there's been some issues with
people
in the kind of outdoor outdoor markets
in the borough and not
implementation of social distancing
measures so
environmental health team are working
very much with that to make sure that
those rules are in place
um and i don't know martin is martin
dylan on the court i don't know if you
want to add anything from a comms
perspective because i know you guys have
been working
quite hard haven't you from a
communications perspective
yeah i mean we've do obviously there's
uh there's a lot of uh well from
uh our point of view there's obviously
there's a media interest a lot of media
and interest in schools and our rates
with once you
do and then again we've been pushing out
a lot of messages
around uh the fact that we are still
subject to restrictions
in traffic and greater manchester so
we've been heavy emphasis
on that and again trying to push out
messages as well
around health and hygiene so again so
we've been doing a lot of work on that
and again that's going to continue uh
some of that supplement and some of the
stuff that's gm wide and some of that's
just traffic focused as well
thanks martin um could i just ask
something um
you know when bars and cafes and stuff
are taking people's um
details when they when they're going in
so that they're so they'll be
available for track and trace at a later
date if necessary
um i have noticed when i've been into a
local cafe that
um people's addresses and
names and telephone numbers have been
left unsupervised and then
i think the qr reader is a really good
idea because obviously you don't have to
then
write stuff down but i just think we
need to be reminding establishments that
actually you've
you've got a responsibility under gdpr
to protect that information because
you know i wouldn't want anybody to be
in a situation where that information
was taken and used wrongly so
if we can remind people when we're doing
the comms around that as well that'd
be really helpful thanks
yeah that's a good point um any further
questions
if we move on who's doing item d is that
you
is that you diane i'm trying to get you
to speak up sorry
through you chad there is a question
from cancer wealth can i believe
sorry sorry sorry come on counselor
wilson sorry didn't you
hi uh this it's kind of with regards to
um
uh the rules for um children
who well and obviously children can't go
around each other's houses for play
dates and
and things like that but my concern of
you know what i'm what i'm
what i'm hearing as a a as a parent is
that is that this
you know i think there's a lot of people
that that
maybe are saying that they don't know
the rules with regards to that there's
some confusion about
you know about what it means when kids
are in a bubble together at school
but also hearing a lot about kids mental
health
and people you know with with genuine
concerns that you know particularly with
teenagers not being able to socialize
that they're you know that and people
are starting to put
those kind of aspects above the risks
concerned with the um
with with the virus and you know i
wonder what we can do to um
you know to well both
reinforce that message to parents that
really you can't have a playdate around
somebody else's house
it may seem like a small thing but
actually you know it's it
it's unacceptable but also how how can
we
positively um you know give people
opportunities
to to socialize safely or how can we get
positive
messages out there about how you can
meet safety rather than consistently
negative messages about you know about
what you can't do
you know um and you know digressed a
little bit but also how
is there any way that you know
particularly with when you know autumn
and winter coming up and you know we've
had this kind of parks culture and
things like that is there anything that
we can do
to create spaces where people can um
you know can can socialize more safely
in our parks and that kind of thing
rather than just basically saying you
cannot do something
go on pick that up all three of you
thank you councillor welton um i do
think that there is some confusion with
the message because i think that because
we hear the government continuously
saying
the rule of six that people think that
that applies in greater manchester in
the rule of six doesn't apply in greater
manchester because we're still in
special um restrictions so i do i do
know that it's
quite confusing and i know that eleanor
and martin have been working really hard
to try and get the message out
um across trafford that you know we are
in a different situation and obviously
looking
to reduce the rate if the rate reduces
and we can go to
the rule of six obviously those those
things will improve for residents so i
think i don't know whether or not
we should look about putting some faqs
onto the um
website with some more specifics around
can i have a play date
no you can't at the minute i think that
some of those things that
but you know going forward we'll be able
to do x y and z if we're if we're under
those um national
measures i don't know whether or not
that's something that we can look at
possibly but the law actually says you
can't go into somebody's house
so there's no there's no sort like
either or or grey area the local says at
the moment you can't go into somebody's
household garden
and i think that's what needs to be
clear martin isn't it because i think
that people hit see the see the prime
minister on the tv
continuously saying rule of six rule of
six but actually there's no
then sort of message to say but you know
those that are in special restrictions
you can't do
going in the garden and stuff and i know
that you and ellen worked really hard
last week to try and get that message
correct on our website and actually in
our comms because people were
complaining that
they didn't understand it and and but i
don't know if there's anything more that
we can do around that
also as well the government's also
advises that basically you shouldn't
there's as we said the law says you
shouldn't meet in the garden but the
advice as well that you shouldn't be
basically anyone anywhere in a public
venue
and that includes parks so it's you know
it's a difficult
message to uh to get across for people
to want to take in
i think i think we are in the difficult
position because it is that
business about what's the law and what's
the advice um
and it the law is very clear and it is
homes and gardens
but the advice is much wider and so
we've got we get quite a lot of kickback
from people
saying you're telling us not to do
things but actually the law
is less um you know that the law is um
less restrictive and then we have other
groups of people saying why aren't you
stopping people from doing things
when it's just advice so it is quite
difficult but
you know our population is i think quite
polarized on some of this about
some people feel we're doing too much
and some people feel we're doing too
little
um so we've tried to separate out now on
the website what's the
law and what you can be fined for and
what the consequences of that
are and what's the advice so that it's
clearer to people
i do think um in general i think the
advice is advice we should all be
following
however i think it is also important for
people's mental health that they get out
and about and that they occasionally see
people who aren't in their family now
you can do that outdoors
walking in a park keeping at that social
distance
and it really is about trying to make
sure that people absolutely remember the
importance of keeping
if you are meeting somebody from outside
your family or outside your social club
outside your bubble making sure that you
are keeping that
that distance from them and absolutely
the rule of six does still apply for us
in those situations
where you're working on the advice
rather than the law
um six is um you know again it's
thinking about
those six and not going different places
with different six people every day that
just is
increasing it and increasing it so it's
really trying to break the roots all the
roots of transmission that this virus
has
and so being outdoors seeing fewer
people and very importantly
keeping distance washing your hands
covering
using the face coverings but remembering
that face covering
gives other people protection from you
far more than it protects you from other
people
so it really is about um you know if
you're wearing your face covering it
it is to stop other people you being
such a danger to others
um and it's sort of a considerate thing
to do but
stay outside wherever you can keep the
numbers down and try and keep a track of
who you're seeing and be symptom aware i
think that's all we can be saying at the
moment
um and really take this seriously
thank you eleanor and we'll be getting
an update on the age well board
i can give a quick headline i don't
think louise could make it today so um
essentially the age well board
um i think met last thursday and it
launched its
uh older people's voice campaign
and that was to coincide with the
international day of older persons
um and essentially it was members of the
public were invited virtually to join
the launch of that strategy
um and it was around kind of seeking the
views of our of our older population
in trafford to ensure that they're kind
of at the heart of decision making and
that their views are heard um so we're
going to take into consideration
everything that was um
talked about and again it's just about
feeding that kind of action plan
into our wider engagement and
communication
strategy thank you perhaps that might be
something that we'll
look at a future board thank you and
if we move on then to um item seven
public engagement board
activity um i think there's been quite a
bit of activity and obviously there's
gonna be
quite a bit more with the um current
rate of infections
is any is there anything that anybody
wants to bring around that that we're
gonna be
looking to and looking for for all the
future meetings
oh it was really just to say if there's
um if there are things that the board
think we're not doing that we need to do
um let us know but also whether there
are things that board members
particularly would like to get involved
in
and lead and progress but also and make
sure that we're being held to account
for things so it's really trying to
it's a plea out to board members to
support us with this and and think about
how
how you can use your networks to help
get these messages across
but also if there are things that you
think we're missing please to let us
know
i don't know donna did you have
something you wanted
no i don't know i think it's just that
point isn't it about um
you know we've communicated um our main
communications have been around our care
homes and around our schools and
you know in care homes we've seen you
know some some tremendous successes
um because of you know the diligence and
the support of all our care home
managers and and um diane's team in
those areas
and i think you know that the actual
emphasis on different messages for
different groups is really really
important
and when you can target it so directly
and specifically to a cohort
you can actually see some real
improvements there so it's how we learn
from those messages i think eleanor
absolutely and it is i think one of the
other things is trying to think with our
care home population that
is picking up councillor welton's point
about mental health that
it's been very very difficult for our
care home population because we have had
to put such tight controls around them
and particularly around visiting for
them
and obviously people are really trying
to think about how do we make
visiting safer for our care home
residents without
particularly thinking that different
people in care homes will have different
um assessments of risk and what they
what risks they want to tolerate but of
course living in a in a group
environment like that
you are very dependent on coming to a
group decision about your risk-taking
um and how we keep you safe while at the
same time allowing people
to have have the visitors and have their
their emotional mental health
needs met as well as protecting their
physical health so
we are it's a tremendously difficult
time i think
and i suppose one of the things i'd
really like us to be thinking about
as a board is how do we have those
conversations with the public
because all of this you know none of us
want to be living in a state
where people are having to be having
things enforced we have to get to a way
where we
we can live and protect ourselves and
protect other people
while not ending up so isolated in our
homes that all sorts of other things go
wrong for us
um particularly through the winter so
it's just really thinking about how we
have those conversations and how we hear
the public voice of that
um because it's it will be different and
different people will think different
things
so how do we how do we really get that
engagement
so that we can design services that that
people want to engage with and feel
makes sense to them
and i think people don't obey rules that
they don't understand
so how do we how do we develop rules and
ways of behaving
that make sense to people
thank you elena um does anybody else
have any comments
no okay we can move on to item a
discussion around all the risks issues
and escalations but i think we've pretty
much
covered that in the previous items and
then
item nine which is an an item of any
other business
is to consider any other items that
people would like us to bring
and to the board so has anybody got
anything that they
are desperately wanting to say and think
that we are missing a trick and we
should be bringing it to the next board
diane did you want to say something yes
thank you
chair it was just really following on
from the care homes item
um hopefully for the next meeting we'll
be coming back with some
um feedback from the representations
that adas and the dphs are putting in
across
gm around visiting for our care home
residents so we are
working as a collective to try and reach
some solutions that can be agreed
ministerially
and but we'll we'll know more in a week
or so
thank you i am and i can't see any
further indications of anybody wanting
to come in
and we are now at 10 58 so we've done
really well we've
managed to cram all that in into 58
minutes
so i'd like to thank you all for
attending thanks to the staff for doing
all the hard work that they've been
doing
and um it will be andrew that will see
you next time and i bet you're all
giving a big
sigh of relief for that so thanks a lot
everybody
nice to see you and thank you for
everybody as contributions
bye thank you bye
you